letzte woche seit langer zeit zum ersten
mal wieder in unsere abstellen kann man
geschaut und gesehen dass wir unmengen
an fand haben dann kam natürlich die
frage auf was wäre wohl das krasseste
was ich mit diesem plan kann schnell
geld
[Musik]
angefangen hat es dann natürlich damit
dass den ganzen land weg gebracht habe
und mich darum gekümmert hat wo ich mehr
fand er bekommt als erstes war der plan
dass ich auf die straße gehe und einfach
fand sammelt dann habe ich aber ebay
kleinanzeigen angeschmissen und jemanden
gefunden der seinen fand kostenlos
abzugeben hat sind auf dem weg zum free
farm dass ich auch kleine anzeichen
gefunden habe das wirklich gestört ist
einfach bares geld gibt aber ich muss
sagen ich habe genau dasselbe in der
kroner zeit schon mal gemacht denn
weniger leute sind auf der straße
weniger leute lassen fand liegen das
bedeutet die leute die tat sammeln und
davon leben haben eine deutlich
schwierigere zeit ich spende das geld
danach an obdachlosenhilfe denn wir
wollen den leuten natürlich nicht im
lohn nehmen nichtsdestotrotz dem auf dem
weg dahin und holen das jetzt von waren
geld ich musste so überzeugendes arbeit
lässt familie brandt gibt weil die
person hat das aus genau derselben
motivation gemachten ich damals bisher
noch nicht die leute unterstützen die
momentan schwierigkeiten haben frank zu
finden und als ich da an kam so komplett
normal gut gekleidet hat die person die
aus dem vertrag wird das eigentlich
leuten geben des wegs brauchen da muss
ich erstmal überzeugungsarbeit leisten
um erklären warum ich das mache das
jetzt für ein youtube-video mache und
ich habe der person versprochen dass ich
das spende deswegen sind jetzt hier
wenig gespendet habe vielen dank an die
person ich weiß dass du das hier sehen
wirst couscous der feind eines virus im
regen
nicht auf der strecke
das ist nun geprägt was wir machen somit
über brandschutz über band und wirst
dann kann ich das vor ihren augen lassen
die rechnung wurde ohne zuletzt gelöscht
gemacht habe dass dies unsere rechnung
10 eur 81 der insgesamt 34 eur 730 die
wir dann zusammen hatten habe ich
angefangen zu suchen auf amazon überall
ich habe nur trash gefunden mit 34 euro
macht man normalerweise so was wie zwei
mal essen gehen oder so bismarck es mir
dann den link der hölle geschickt
sorry nochmal über diesen link kann sich
dann für weniger als zehn euro flüge
nach budapest alicante mailand wien
sofia london und eben auch palmer
gefunden dann habe ich meinen flug von
hamburg nach palma für weniger als acht
euro gebucht weil ich eben kumpel in
hamburg besucht habe der rückflug ging
von palma nach köln für 24 euro 17 damit
hat mir unser fand geld genau ausgereizt
und einfach ein fucking flug nach malle
gebucht dann habe ich meine sachen
gepackt und ab zum flughafen so gestört
es fühlt sich so falsch an hier zu sein
und meine wäre auch dumm genug in diesen
zeiten zu kriegen
glätte flughafen ist einfach leer alle
geschäfte sind zu die ganzen gänge sind
nur super vereinzelte terminals haben
offen sieht auch so aus als wird der
flug komplett leer acht euro für acht
euro mehrere tausend kilometer durch
komplett europa zu fliegen ist so falsch
liegen vermeiden so viel es geht und vor
allem iv 8 euro das ist wirklich einfach
hobbes und sollte noch verboten seien
natürlich ist mir bewusst dass ich die
auch damit unterstützen dass ich jetzt
fliege aber es ist eben zu
demonstrationszwecken passiert fragt
rasiert alles dabei hat sie nicht
zumindest nichts was ich wirklich
gebrauchen kann
30 grad ab mit komplettem zubehör wiesen
kopfhörer an der badehose in eine decke
und wechsel unterwäsche das macht
vielleicht ist euch aufgefallen dass ich
das gesamte geld für hin und rückflug
aus gegeben habe was bedeutet dass ich
keinen einzigen cent für unterkunft
essen oder trinken auf mallorca hat
angefangen hat es war natürlich schon im
flugzeug weil ich konnte ab dem
zeitpunkt wo ich am flughafen war habe
ich wirklich komplett durchgezogen und
nichts mehr gekauft und wirklich dann
ohne geld gelebt das ist meine
kostenlose aus heute diesen flug
begleitung extrem und die andere hälfte
behalte ich mir später an gesagt wenn
wir den 45 begleitung einmal zu fragen
wenn irgendwas furcht zu leben als
erstes hat sie mir ihr privates wasser
angeboten gedacht und was in den becher
zu tun aber das war mir dann eins zu
viel deswegen bin ich bei milch problem
dass wir keine kondensmilch oder so
sondern ganz normale milch
das war eine erste gute versorgung und
dann nach zwei stunden flug war ich
tatsächlich auf mallorca nicht wirklich
geschafft ich habe mir meinen flug nach
mallorca gestört ich bin da ist s 21
grad absolutes ziel charlotte ja es ist
komplett gestört und auch hier natürlich
alles komplett leer ist
ich hatte ja auch ins angekündigt dass
diese woche eigentlich 100.000
abonnenten special kommen soll ich
steckte aber unendlich viel arbeit rein
und suche noch partner die mich dabei
unterstützen können deswegen plane ich
das bei 200.000 abonnenten zu machen um
einfach ein bisschen mehr zeit zu haben
wenn ihr mich um meine arbeit also
unterstützen wollt dann lasst mir in abu
dhabi schneller wir das gemeinsam
schaffen desto schneller kommt auch das
abo special und das wird wirklich
jeglichen rahmen sprengen ich danke
küste viel spaß weiter mit dem
eigentlich hatte ich vor andere touris
zu fragen und bei denen im taxi
mitfahren kann weil ich ja eigentlich
noch gar kein ziel habe wo ich
eigentlich wirklich raus kommen daher
aber irgendwie niemand rumsteht und ich
weiß wo die ganzen leute von meinem flug
sind habe ich mich jetzt kurzfristig
dazu entschlossen einfach so von hier
ist freight an den strand zu laufen das
ist ein kleiner ort ich habe keine
ahnung wieder heißt das sind circa 35
minuten zu fuß und dann werde ich
schauen ob ich da irgendwo am strand
brennen kann oder ob es eigene andere
geile möglichkeit gibt aber ich muss
definitiv linken ort weil ich habe geist
kein hunger und geist gang durstig
bezweifelt sogar dass ich jetzt
überhaupt noch irgendwas zu essen findet
außerdem hat das pärchen das neben mir
saß im flieger mehr halben liter wasser
geschenk beim aus dem flugzeug rausgehen
weil ich den von der idee erzählt habe
vielen vielen dank ich weiß dass sie das
hier sehen werden ich danke euch
vielmals musste die ganze zeit nur durch
die industriegebiete laufen als ich
dachte wert abgesprochen aber guckt euch
das an
wir sind da hier ist der ort der erste
tennisplatz und laut navi müsste da
vorne direkt am strand sein und damit
auch unser heutiger schlafplatz komplett
leergefegt also hier ist keine
menschenseele unterwegs essen
das wird schwer wir sind da spielgruppen
alle ich glaube da irgendwas for free zu
bekommen ist genauso unmöglich wie im
flugzeug zum glück habe ich das wasser
geschenkt bekommen
das meldet alter wir haben es geschafft
die erste hürde zumindest in die
richtung sieht sehr gut aus ich gehe
hier in die richtung locations und da
vorne noch so ein bisschen licht
leuchtet ihr könnt euch nicht vorstellen
wie er nicht da jetzt einfach einchecken
würde als perfekt beschlossen
ich probiere kostenlosen urlaub zu
machen und deswegen wollte fragen ob
irgendwelche essen hat was ihr
wegschmeißen würdet als probier eine
nacht hier kostenlos zu leben und hier
einen tag urlaub zu machen
lenka hajeckova tsch komplett gestört
das ist mir unendlich unangenehm aber
ich hab es tatsächlich geschafft und
habe diesen kleber friebe kommt bloß ein
bier wirklich dass das unangenehmste was
jemals in meinem leben gemacht habe weil
ich könnte sie aber zahlen also es
wirklich schrecklich wirklich vielen
vielen dank an antalya ich glaube jetzt
gehe ich hier einfach mal am strand
entlang habe nicht das gefühl dass es
sehr viel weniger abgelegen wird aber
aber diese stelle hier scheint mir so
ein bisschen blick geschützt von da aus
also werde ich mich glaub mich hier
einfach mal breit machen dieses wasser
das von den sitznachbarn im flugzeug
geschenkt bekommen haben rettet mir
jetzt wirklich in asch bloß eine der
wenigen nützlichen sachen die ich dabei
habe eine decke will ich jetzt ja schon
wirklich so 15 minuten rum wie ich das
im endeffekt wirklich mache wo ich mich
hinlegen und so desto mehr ich darüber
nachdenke desto weniger kann ich mich
mit der idee anfreunden hier wirklich
irgendwo zu schlafen noch fitter gegen
alle spanier aber so ein unterbezahlter
inselbewohner würde sich schon über so
eine kamera unseren macbook freund weiß
nicht ob ich hier ein auge zugedrückt
bekomme und dann bin ich tatsächlich die
komplette nacht von a nach b gestreut
hat kein auge zubekommen bin wirklich
einfach promenade hoch und runter ich
habe auf dieser parkbank schild es waren
mehrere leute unterwegs das war wirklich
die absolute renner
das war mit abstand die besten acht die
ich jemals hatte
ich bin wirklich überhaupt nicht zur
ruhe gekommen hier sind die ganze gegend
welche mühelos vorbei gelaufen oder
zumindest hatte ich das gefühl dass hier
die ganze erlegen jemand vorbei läuft
nichts desto trotz ist die nacht jetzt
vorbei und ich habe da da da
eigentlich überall hier an der promenade
verbracht das soll uns aber nicht davon
abhalten dass wir jetzt den krassesten
kostenlosen urlaub haben den man sich
überhaupt nur vorstellen kann und der
startet mit einer runde im meer
da vorne geht jetzt geht die sonne auf
und entschuldigt bitte meine friese
dafür habe ich jetzt wegen dem grund
gerade keine zeit
ich kann jetzt mit der kamera natürlich
nicht vernünftig schwimmen gehen das ist
klar aber ich stelle die gleich einfach
weg und dann schwimme ich ein paar
runden das könnt ihr für acht euro
bekommen für acht euro habe ich schon
schlechtere dinge erlebt im meer
schwimmen gehen schön und gut aber ich
habe geisteskranken hunger wirklich ich
bin mir ziemlich sicher dass ich wieder
zu den kebab laden von gestern gehen
könnte und die mir wieder was for free
geben könnten weil die so korrekt waren
ich bezweifle aber stark dass die ihren
37 offen haben und mir wäre es keine
unangenehmen jetzt noch mal dahin zu
gehen und deshalb habe ich mir überlegt
dass ich mich bei einem hotel kostenlos
rein schmuggeln werde um dort kostenlos
zu frühstücken ich habe keine ahnung ob
das funktioniert aber wir glauben jetzt
die verschiedenen hotels ab und schauen
ob wegen hoher einkommen jetzt gerade
drei hotels bei google rausgesucht und
wäre mit dem allerbesten staaten was
hier direkt um die ecke ist das hier ist
das erste hotel wo es probieren werden
kamera kommt in rucksack und dann lässt
das hotel unfassbar neue und moderne
schätzungsweise letztes jahr gebaut die
securitys ungefähr so motiviert wie ich
mit 16 beim zeitungsaustragen also war
es auch kein problem
beim buffet zu landen
warte ich mal kurz das ist lang da nicht
einfach so rum das habe ich mir genau
nach meinen anforderungen beraten lassen
nach fünf minuten am buffet war ich mir
meiner situation so sicher dass ich mir
eben dieses am leiter braten lassen und
eben auch meine große kamera ausgepackt
habe und die einfach auf dem tisch
stehen hatte vom frühstück direkt an den
pool komplett auf dem präsentierteller
alter nach vorne sitzen die ganzen leute
und sind beim frühstücken und gucken
richtung pool und ich sitze am pool wenn
das nicht der fall wäre
der puls schon geöffnet hätte dann würde
ich jetzt noch eine runde schwimmen
gehen weil das interessiert hier
wirklich absolut niemanden aber dass
beides nicht der fall ist werde ich
jetzt meine restliche zeit hier einfach
so am pool genießen traum wie gestört
kann dieses ende vom video werden alter
ich bin einfach hier ist es halt
niemanden interessiert und hat vor
friedel frühstückt es hat niemanden
interessiert natürlich bin ich nach dem
frühstück an die rezeption gegangen und
habe gesagt was vorgefallen ist und habe
mein frühstück gezahlt also ich habe
nicht geklaut ich wollte einfach nur
zeigen dass es theoretisch möglich
gewesen wären das so zu machen und damit
endet dann wohl mein urlaub auf mallorca
50 euro ich hoffe euch hat das video
gefallen wenn ja lass mir gerne ein
leichter ich begebe mich jetzt zu fuß
zurück zum flughafen um fliege zurück
nach köln es war ein absoluter traum bis
nächste woche sonntag
[Applaus]
ja